well the rest of the world is busy
talking about Joaquin Phoenix's new
Joker well we've already done that one
twice so instead I'm going back to
revisit the Dark Knight and you know
what it is a miracle that nobody in
Gotham figures out the Bruce Wayne
Batman connection I mean think about it
Coleman Reese aka Bruce Wayne's
accountant goes on live TV saying that
he's gonna reveal Batman's identity I
mean who else is he exposing here people
the Wayne Enterprises HRF looks like
Gotham's greatest villain isn't the
Joker it's basic critical thinking hello
internet welcome to film theory the show
that at this point deserves its own
place and how it should have ended x'v
Ilyn pub because of how frequently we
step up to defend history's most iconic
bad guys
Thanos scar Light Yagami dr.
Doofenshmirtz but today we're actually
tackling one of the biggest most iconic
bad guys of them all
Heath Ledger's Joker from The Dark
Knight now I know I'm not the first one
to suggest that the Joker might be the
good guy in this movie
in fact one reddit theory went viral
about this exact topic a few years ago
which then got him hired by us as a
researcher sub Zack but a lot of time
has passed since that original theory
and so with a very different take on the
Joker currently now in theaters our
newly combined theorist forces wanted to
revisit that post one final time and at
this point we're both convinced the
world has been watching this movie
completely backwards the Joker is the
hero in the Dark Knight he's the hero
that Gotham deserves this isn't just us
overthinking things either it's clearly
an intentional decision on the part of
the creative team working on this movie
so suit up and prepare to watch your
world burn along with everything you
thought you knew about this movie first
let's set the stage by talking a little
about Gotham the primary setting for the
Nolan trilogy of Batman movies starting
with Batman Begins and ending with the
Dark Knight Rises
now these films are as much about Gotham
as they are about Bruce Wayne when the
series first begins were presented with
a Gotham that's completely corrupt
overrun with
crime mafia bosses and paid off police
officers in fact the villains plot in
Batman Begins is all about correcting
Gotham by purging it founders time ask
city has become a breeding ground for
suffering and injustice it is beyond
saving and must be allowed to die and if
fake Ra's al Ghul here sounds a bit
harsh well that's because he is but he's
also speaking from past experience he
was a go through before of course in
fact if you rewatch Batman Begins and
only focus on the League of Shadows and
Ra's al Ghul's motivation its hammered
over our heads repeatedly that their
only goal is to hit reset on Gotham a
city that they consider to have become
so rotten that they can no longer save
it forest grows too wild a purging fire
is inevitable a natural movement back to
harmony will be unstoppable this time or
at least it would have been unstoppable
if it hadn't been for that meddling bat
despite Roz pumping fear gas into the
city Gotham is eventually saved by its
greatest hero Batman or is it you see
movie 2 the Dark Knight picks up about a
year later and things are looking much
better for Gotham than when we last left
him oh sure Batman is cleaning up petty
criminals here and there on a
case-by-case basis he's been powerless
to do anything about the true
institutional corruption that pervades
the city the Mafia is still running wild
corruption is still everywhere in the
police station heck we're even starting
to see the negative effects of Batman
himself in the city despite trying to
clean up crime Batman's vigilante
justice has only resulted in one major
thing escalation of the criminals the
looming threat of Batman being out there
threatening to foil any underhanded
behavior has forced the criminals to get
more extreme in their behaviors they now
use bigger guns and have themselves more
protection it was actually something the
soon-to-be Commissioner Gordon worried
about in the first movie of the trilogy
what about escalation this collision we
start Eric's
my automatics they buy automatics we
start wearing Kevlar they buy
armor-piercing rounds and what do we
have at the beginning of Dark Knight a
lowly drug dealer traveling heavily
armed with multiple guard dogs
Gordon's fears have become fully
realized escalation is happening and
it's all the result of Batman enter the
Joker who describes himself as an agent
of chaos I'm a dog chasing cars I
wouldn't know what to do with one if I
caught him he Rob's banks blows up
Hospital sets up impossible game theory
esque scenarios where lives are
constantly being threatened wait a
minute game theory I love that show any
way you slice it he is a villain in
every sense of the word or at least he
is until you actually look at his
actions because by the end of the Dark
Knight Gotham that city that was so
corrupted had to be destroyed in Batman
Begins yeah by the end of the second
movie it's cured it's saved and it's
saved by one man not Bruce Wayne but by
the Joker you see it's easy to walk away
from this movie just reciting the
catchphrases I don't know what got these
scars
it's time for Gotham to get the hero it
needs not the hero it thinks it deserves
but if you pay attention to the plot The
Joker's ability to understand human
behavior and set up dominoes to fall in
just the right way is practically
ingenious when the movie begins we watch
as the Joker robs a bank not for the
money but to alert the mafia to the fact
that their money is being actively
tracked this causes their accountant
loud to run away with all the gang money
to Hong Kong
Joker uses this to convince the combined
gangs of Gotham that Lau's gonna reveal
everything to Batman unless the gangs
give him half their money to kill the
Batman first Batman has no jurisdiction
he'll find him and make him squeal when
Batman does in fact do exactly what the
Joker predicted and extradite Lau
forcibly Lau starts singing like a bird
and the gangs give in to the Joker's
demands but Joker isn't content with
just half the money at this point he
allows himself to
get caught by the police in order to
kidnap Lau and get himself all of the
gangs money money which he then promptly
burns in this series of moves the Joker
has now bankrupted the Mafia the gangs
of Gotham are now broken and penniless
something that no one has been able to
accomplish yet so with that out of the
way the Joker then turns his attention
towards the final evil that's plaguing
Gotham that lunatic jumping off of
rooftops in a ninja costume that the
police refuse to do anything about
Batman but his plan isn't to kill him oh
no killing the Batman would just
encourage more of the Jalan T's to take
up his mantle just like the random dudes
that we see at the beginning of the
movie who are woefully underprepared for
the world of hurt that they're getting
themselves into the only way to end the
Batman problem is to get him to quit to
retire to disappear and instead have the
city recognize a more wholesome brand
safe traditional hero to do this joker
lures Batman to a construction site
using hostages while his real works its
magic in the background you see by
manipulating Gotham's golden boy Harvey
Dent into becoming a homicidal monster
Joker leaves Batman with little choice
but to kill him Batman is forced to
break his one rule and in the process he
realizes that he has to retire to
salvage Harvey's reputation and give
Gotham the hero he can believe in he
tells Gordon to blame all of Harvey's
murders on himself and Batman just gives
up that's it game over he retires for
the next eight years up until the events
of Dark Knight Rises Batman stays
retired so at the end of Dark Knight we
have ourselves three key things one a
destabilized mafia that's penniless to
most of that mafia and corrupted
officials in jail thanks in part to the
passing of the dent Act which honored
the supposed hero of Gotham by denying
appeals to criminals found guilty in
those corruption cases and three no more
lawless vigilantes roaming the streets
that means that for eight years after
the events of the Dark Knight Gotham was
the paradise that Bruce Wayne and Ra's
al Ghul never thought would come the
Mafia defeated dozens of corrupt cops
either discovered or kill
the ineffective alcoholic Commissioner
replaced by the incorruptible Jim Gordon
and no need for heavily armed vigilantes
and that dear theorists was Joker's
intent the entire time he saved a city
that everyone thought was beyond saving
no the first thing that a lot of fans
are probably thinking is no Joker's an
agent of chaos you played that exact
clip earlier in this episode you know
what I am I'm a dog chasing cars I
wouldn't know what to do with one if I
caught it but can we really believe what
the Joker's saying here of course not
it's the Joker we're talking about just
think about the logistics of his plan in
the first place Joker had to think about
the actions and reactions of the Mafia
the police and Batman to manipulate them
all for one undeniable example just
think about his final battle against
Batman he sets up a situation where the
alleged hostages are actually his goons
and vice versa but the SWAT team and
Batman that's coming in doesn't know
that so Joker is effectively pitting
Batman against the SWAT team who's
supposedly on his side
he's even prepared for this final
showdown using dogs which were effective
against Batman up until recent
improvements to his suit as well as
setting up the floor with deployable
nets that entangled a bat this is
clearly not somebody just doing things
for the heck of it and seeing what
happens this is someone who makes and
flawlessly executed very elaborate very
sophisticated plans plans mind you that
involves specifically eliminating the
most dangerous and corrupt people in
Gotham don't get me wrong
Joker absolutely harms innocents but
think of it like cracking a few eggs to
make an omelet
Harvey Dent was willing to let the top
Mafia dons walk Batman was only ever
thinking about how to solve a single
crime or fight a small group of villains
at any given moment Joker meanwhile was
playing the long game the big picture
trying to fight the corruption
underlying all of Gotham's problems
Joker specifically tells Batman about
his plan as he dangles off the side of
the construction site in a fistfight
with you
you need an ace in the hole if Joker
really wanted Harvey Dent to kill
Gordon's family and become a monster for
all of Gotham to see why would he give
Batman a chance to stop him at all why
not let Batman realize the colossal
mistake that he made the next day when
he reads it in the papers that's because
the Joker doesn't really want Harvey to
become that monster
he just needs Batman to think Harvey
will become that monster so that Batman
will make the sacrifice that he
ultimately does Joker as he himself
admits is fighting a battle for Gotham's
soul not to corrupt it but to save it in
a way that only he is capable of no I'm
not saying that the Joker's a good
person or that anything he's doing is
worthy of replication in fact I do
believe that Joker's rather sick so
completely driven by consequentialist
philosophy that he completely ignores
the pain that he creates along the way
my only argument here is that Joker's
intent was not to watch the world burn
as some memorable quotes would have you
believe but instead to cure Gotham of
its pervasive corruption I mean consider
that dinner party scene in the middle of
the movie he takes a party filled with
rich socialites hostage and does what
nothing I mean he scares them with his
little scar story and he gets Batman to
jump out a window and that's it no one
else is harmed no one else is robbed no
one's targeted or killed he focuses on
Batman and then he leaves and it does
seem like the movie intends for this to
be the case the entire time Alfred in
the middle of the movie has a story that
he used to try and explain the erratic
behavior of the Joker super famous scene
from The Dark Knight but when you
actually stop and look at his story it
doesn't really seem to mean what he
thinks it means to refresh you on the
contents of that story a thief was
stealing precious gems from a local
government but rather than selling him
he was just handing them out to the
children because as Alfred put it
because he thought it was good spoil the
only problem is that Alfred is totally
and completely wrong about the thief's
intent let's listen to Alfred set up
this story a long time ago I was in
Burma my friends and I were working for
government they were trying to find a
loyalty of tribal leaders by bribing
them with precious stones that's right
these weren't just random shipments of
valuables between companies these stones
were specifically being used to bribe
tribal leaders into submission the
locals had every reason to try and
intercept those caravans to try and
protect their own sovereignty the
British controlled Burma from 1824 to
1948 and just like well pretty much
everywhere the English invaded the
Burmese people weren't particularly keen
on this foreign power impressing their
values and way of life on to the
indigenous people half a world away
alfrid thought that the thief just
wanted to watch the world burn because
he believed in chaos but in the end it's
Alfred and his friends that were doing
all of the burning abandon the forest in
Burma did you catch him yes we burned a
forest down if the thief truly wanted to
burn the world down well it wouldn't be
hard to set the forest ablaze as Joker
points out himself
I enjoy dynamite and gunpowder and
gasoline it's ultimately the men who
think they're protecting justice who
wind up burning the forest down and they
blamed the man who just wants to save
their home that's true of Alfred's story
and it's a direct parallel with Joker's
role in the Dark Knight you can't see
yourself as the villain when you think
you're the hero and that my friends is
the twist it also happens to be the
cruelest joke of them all but hey that's
just a theory ah film theory and sure
dynomite gunpowder and gasoline may be
cheap but they could be even cheaper
thanks to the sponsor for today's
episode honey
you ever buy something online and then
find out you could have gotten it for
Less enough to drive a person crazy and
while Batman may be the hero that Gotham
deserves honey is the hero the Internet
deserves
honey is a browser extension that scans
the internet for coupon codes and other
discounts and then like magic it
automatically applies the one with the
biggest savings
to your cart at checkout it knows about
every coupon code sale or discounted
over 20,000 sites like Amazon eBay Best
Buy Target or literally nothing can hide
from honey just like no criminal can
hide from bat in fact the viewers of
film Theory who've already installed
honey have saved themselves in total a
hundred and sixty one thousand dollars
and it doesn't even have to be big stuff
either I just got myself an order from
Pizza Hut to have myself a personal
Friday night pizza party it saved me
eight dollars and 33 cents on something
that I literally buy every single week I
mean eight dollars and 33 cents that I'd
be overpaying every week that adds up a
couple weeks and I'm saving myself
enough to buy a switch game and best of
all honey is entirely free if you're
good at something never do it for free
Joker apparently has never heard of
honey because it is indeed free it gets
itself a commission from the seller for
every deal that it helps you save money
on that is how easy this thing is there
is no reason to keep throwing that money
away all it takes to install is just to
clicks click one getting the honey for
free and join honey dot-com / film
theorist or since film series is really
long to type in just to use the link
below and secondly install that's all
you need to do that is that not even
billionaires like Bruce Wayne want to
waste their money so make the smart
decision make the Batman decision join
honey calm / film theorists now if
you'll excuse me I've got myself a pizza
that I saved eight dollars and 33 cents
on waiting outside this closet see you
all next week join honey